the white house and republican governors
they faced some heavy criticism for
states that are reopening
but now blue states are starting to
follow suit with very little pushback
california new york colorado and
washington all slowly starting to lift
restrictions
and president trump is arguing that it
is necessary
if they held people any longer with the
shutdowns and
you're going to lose people that way too
and you already have i'm sure
but between drug abuse and i mean they
say
suicide a lot of different things
there's no wind just so you know
there's no great wind one way or the
other
so jesse i don't really understand how
reopening has become a republican versus
democrat
issue since the virus doesn't
discriminate um
and the lockdown didn't discriminate it
affects
all of us and help me understand that
gladly because we've covered this pretty
methodically for the last two months and
here's what i've observed
when a democrat governor locks down
they get praised when they open things
back up they're ignored
when a republican governor locks down
they're ignored
and when they open things back up
they're attacked that tells me two
things
the media loves democrats and the media
loves lockdowns
there you go dana it's called deductive
reasoning i mean
think about it you had the governor kemp
in georgia
who basically said we're going to open
things up nearly two weeks ago
and guess what happened not everybody
died and the world didn't come to an end
as a matter of fact the number of cases
has slowly declined
in two weeks same thing with florida
governor desantis
he had a pretty liberal beach policy and
county by county lockdown approach
they were supposed to be the next new
york big elderly population
didn't happen so obviously
it's politicized and i think we all know
why
yeah i know i was being a little
facetious i'm really not that um
daft but um i was just trying to make
the point greg that
it really is affecting everybody and and
the reopening is affecting
everybody as well i mean it's in some
places it's going to be quite slow and
there's even some businesses
like restaurants who are maybe limited
to 25
capacity who think i can't make a profit
with 25
capacity so they might not open at all
okay so this is where it's
you don't go down party lines ideology
you go down
adults versus children this is an
issue in which you have you are facing
supremely adult
questions adults unlike children
have to discuss risk and benefits every
day of their decisions
children don't so i have a new law i
call it the essie cup law
in honor of the reigning queen of adding
nothing to a conversation
until it's over so when chris christie
says
or tries to make the adult point that
late these future decisions regarding
lockdowns they're gonna carry a risk
of death then you'll see the cowardly
gawker
with no skin in the game again who makes
no adult decisions
will say hmm he'll be there to pick it
off and go
but people will die you are insensitive
to death
and you should go to a crowded place and
feed the hungry
because you don't care so that is the
childlike answer every time
and i think we could save our viewers a
lot of time
if we just cancel out these obvious
points like
adults know that every death is too much
right we know that
we also know that opening up is going to
increase risk
we also accept and share the risk every
day with different
actions so if your argument still lives
in that territory
you are a child and you should not be
allowed at the adults table
when we are talking about these
decisions so if you say that there is a
risk
the media will accuse you of murder no
matter what because they're children
when the states reopen and the leaders
are taking a calculated risk
blue or red state we have to give them
the leeway and not accuse them of murder
because that's infantile because we know
we're we're
adults we've lived in these lives we
understand risk and benefit
so do not listen to the children
juan what about the fact that there's
been a lot of moving of the goal post
maybe from the left in the media
in some cases where the goal of
flattening the curve was so that you
didn't overwhelm the hospital systems
and if that goal was achieved and now
you go to reopen the goal is not
to shut down until we have a vaccine
right
no not at all in fact i think the goal
is as you were saying to make sure that
the hospitals maintain capacity
but also and i think this is really
critical speaking at the adult table if
i might
that we have public trust public trust
because you can reopen things but if the
public doesn't trust that they won't get
sick
and that's not necessarily mean they'll
be hospitalized dana or that they'll die
but that they won't get sick
they won't trust you and come out to
your restaurant
i think i saw numbers today 80 percent
say they won't go to a movie theater
70 percent not willing to go to the gym
or
a restaurant 60 not even willing to go
to a retail clothing store
so i think you have to understand it's
about engendering
public trust in terms of how public
leaders speak to the people
and if it's all cheerleading that's not
trust
deagon do businesses have maybe a role
as well as they like we talked to the
starbucks ceo today
finding some mitigation measures to try
to engender that trust with consumers so
that they will feel comfortable coming
into the shops
they already are there's a shake shack
that's open right down the street from
here so they're about protecting
their employees and the customers but i
just want to highlight something that
we've known
all along and we heard it over and over
again we must protect
the most vulnerable in this country we
must protect the most at risk
and in terms of public trust that is not
something that happened
in new york state new york new york
state in
march mandated that nursing homes had to
take coven 19 patients
back in that were discharged from
hospitals
and today we found out that 1700
previously undisclosed
deaths and nursing homes and adult care
facilities happened in this state more
than 4 800
elderly people have died from coven 19
and nursing homes
since march the 1st and i just find this
heartbreaking and and
almost malicious what they have done to
people who we should have cared for
with the greatest heart in the greatest
head and it's disgusting and i think
about that yes and i read that um
like if it's if that's you was your wife
or your husband your grandmother
your mother um your sister uh they had
about another 10 years
uh to live on average um but for those
who got coven 19 went back to the
nursing home and the state and the state
and the state was warned by doctor
upon doctor about the devastating
consequences of this and they
did it anyway